Vamos a seguir explorando todos estos métodos
para resolver sistemas de ecuaciones
y en esta ocasión quiero ver el método de suma
y resta o de eliminación, es el mismo.
Y bueno,
para esto me voy a tomar dos ecuaciones,
la ecuación "3x" más "4y" igual a 2.5
y la ecuación "5x" menos "4y" esto igual a 25.5...
a 25.5...
y bueno, recuerda que lo que estoy buscando
es un par ordenado "x", "y"
que cumpla ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente
o si lo vemos de una manera gráfica,
la intersección de las dos rectas,
de una manera gráfica
cada una de estas ecuaciones representa una recta
y lo que estaría buscando es
la intersección de estas dos rectas.
Ahora bien, pensemos un poco en esta
ecuación que tengo de amarillo.
Lo que quiero preguntarme yo en un principio
es si a esta ecuación de amarillo le puedo
sumar o restar algo, de tal manera que me
quede una ecuación con solamente una incógnita
y la respuesta no parece tan trivial,
¿por qué?
porque si yo agarro algo que tenga que ver con "x"
y se lo sumo o se lo resto a esta ecuación,
me va a seguir quedando una ecuación
que tenga que ver con "x" y con "y".
Bueno, pero qué va a pasar si en lugar de pensar en un término que tenga que ver con "x" y con "y",
sumamos mejor otra ecuación,
sumamos estas dos ecuaciones, de tal manera
que se cancele todo lo que tenga que ver con "y",
es decir, lo que voy a hacer del lado
derecho es sumar estas dos expresiones,
mientras que del lado izquierdo
voy a sumar estas dos cantidades.
Y por lo tanto me queda una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita,
sé que esto no parece nada obvio,
sin embargo ahorita que resolvamos este ejercicio te va a quedar mucho más claro.
Y seguramente me vas a decir,
oye Sal, ¿qué te pasa?
cómo está eso de que puedes sumar ecuaciones
y bueno, es que realmente
velo de la siguiente manera,
si tenemos una ecuación
de la forma "ax" más "by" igual a "c",
tenemos una ecuación,
y yo le agrego de ambos lados lo mismo,
entonces la igualdad se mantiene, es decir,
si yo sumo o resto la misma cantidad de ambos lados,
supongamos "d", entonces como sabemos que
"d" es igual a "d", la igualdad se mantiene
y me quedaría, "ax" más "by" más "d",
esto es igual a "c" más "d" y se sigue cumpliendo
esta igualdad, es decir, que si hacemos la
misma operación de un lado de la ecuación,
para que se mantenga la igualdad,
tenemos que hacer la misma operación
del otro lado de la ecuación.
Esto ya lo hemos visto varias veces,
así que regresando a esta idea,
si yo tengo aquí 2 ecuaciones y a la primera ecuación
le sumo la segunda ecuación, realmente lo que estoy
diciendo es que del lado izquierdo voy a sumar
"5x" menos "4y"
y del lado derecho voy a sumar 25.5
y en este momento es
cuando tú te debes de preguntar,
¿pero estas dos expresiones son equivalentes?
La respuesta es que sí,
"5x" menos "4y" es igual a 25.5
porque esto es lo que nos dice la otra ecuación.
Por lo tanto,
como "5x" menos "4y" es igual a 25.5,
lo que estoy sumando del lado izquierdo
es igual a lo que estoy sumando del lado derecho
y es justo por eso que mi igualdad se conserva,
así que vamos a hacerlo.
"3x" más "5x" es "8x", "4y" menos "4y"
estos dos se eliminan,
si te das cuenta son operaciones contrarias,
tengo "4y" y después le quito "4y",
pues estos dos se cancelan,
se van o me dan 0,
es como si tuviera "0y",
pero "0y" pues es lo mismo que 0,
"8x" más "0y" es igual a 2.5 más 25.5,
lo cual es 28.
Y aquí quiero que te des cuenta,
que ya tengo una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita,
"8x" igual a 28,
una ecuación bastante fácil de resolver,
porque si yo divido entre 8 ambos
lados de la ecuación, me queda que "x"
es igual a 28 entre 8,
lo cual ya es un resultado numérico,
28 entre 8 es lo mismo que 7/2 o 3.5,
7 entre 2 es 3.5.
Y ya tengo un valor para "x",
¿cómo lo encontré?
sumando estas dos ecuaciones,
porque al sumar estas dos ecuaciones me di cuenta que
me iba a quedar con una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita.
Y bueno, ahora que tengo el valor de "x"
voy a sustituir este valor en alguna de las dos
ecuaciones para encontrar el valor de "y".
Y mejor voy a tomar la primera ecuación,
entonces me queda,
3 que multiplica a "x", pero "x" vale 7/2,
3 por 7/2 más "4y"
esto tiene que ser igual a 2.5,
estoy sustituyendo el valor de "x"
para encontrar mi valor de "y"
y el 2.5 lo voy a escribir como 5/2,
para que todo viva en el mundo de las fracciones.
Y ahora si, vamos a despejar a "y",
entonces me queda 3 por 7/2 es 21/2,
más "4y" esto es igual a 5/2 y ahora voy a restar de ambos lados de la ecuación, 21/2,
aquí voy a restar 21/2, aquí voy a restar 21/2 de tal manera que estos 2 se van a cancelar
y del lado izquierdo solamente me queda "4y",
estos dos se van
y después del lado derecho me queda 5/2 menos 21/2, lo cual es -16/2 ...
-16/2 que es lo mismo que, bueno,
déjame ponerlo así primero , -16/2...
-16/2.
Muy bien y ahora como ya no tengo mucho espacio
voy a agarrar otro color y voy a seguir acá...
"4y" es igual ¿a quién?
Ojo, aquí estoy escribiendo la continuación
y 16/2 es lo mismo que 8,
entonces me queda "4y" igual a -8
y dividiendo ambos lados de la ecuación entre 4,
me queda que "y" es igual a -2.
Y perfecto, entonces ya tengo que la solución
es "x" igual a 7/2, "y" igual a -2
o el punto de intersección
de estas dos rectas es el punto 7/2, -2.
Y bueno, sería muy bueno verificar que cumple
ambas ecuaciones, vamos a intentarlo para
la ecuación de abajo,
al menos para quedarnos con esa seguridad.
Tengo 5 que multiplica a "x" menos "4y" igual
a 25.5, 5 por 7/2 es 35/2
y a esto le tengo que quitar -2 por 4, lo cual es -8,
¿y cuánto es esto?
35/2 que es 17.5 más 8, esto es igual a 25.5,
sí funciona esta ecuación.
35/2 es 17.5 y a esto lo sumo 8 me da 25.5
Así que ahora vamos a resolver un problema
que tenga que ver con un sistema de ecuaciones
y que a este sistema de ecuaciones lo resolvamos
por el método de eliminación
o de suma y resta.
¿Así que qué dice el problema?
Nadia y Pedro visitan una tienda de dulces.
Nadia compró 3 chocolates
y 4 gomitas por 2.84 pesos.
Pedro, por su parte, compró también 3 chocolates,
pero a él solo le alcanzó para una gomita
y se gasto 1 peso con 79 centavos.
¿Cuánto vale cada chocolate y cada
gomita en esta tienda de dulces?
Y bueno, lo primero que vamos a hacer
es bautizar variables,
así que me voy a tomar de nuevo
"x" y "y" y voy a decir,
sea "x" el precio de cada chocolate
y sea "y" el precio de cada una de las gomitas,
así que déjame ponerlo,
"y" es el precio de cada una de las gomitas
y bueno, ahora que ya tengo cada una
de mis variables definidas,
pues ahora vamos a pensar
en hacer las ecuaciones,
¿y que ecuaciones tengo?
Digo, tres veces, si yo compro 3 chocolates
y además compro 4 gomitas, me gasto 2 pesos
con 84 centavos, por lo tanto "3x",
3 por el costo de cada uno de los chocolates más 4,
porque compré 4 gomitas por el precio
de cada una de las gomitas,
esto tiene que ser igual a 2.84,
bueno, esto es lo que nos dice
la primera oración y esto fue lo que compró Nadia,
ojo, estamos hablando de Nadia,
ahora vamos a hablar de Pedro, Pedro compró
también 3 chocolates, por lo tanto "3x",
3 por el precio de los chocolates,
pero a él solamente le alcanzó para comprar 1 gomita,
por lo tanto más "y",
esto tiene que ser igual a 1.79.
Y digo 1 gomita por el precio de lo que costó
cada una de las gomitas y fíjate que ya con
esto tengo escritas mis dos ecuaciones,
que por cierto podemos resolver de varios métodos,
como el método de suma y resta que es como
lo vamos a resolver o sustitución o método
gráfico y bueno, de hecho si lo quisieras
hacer por método gráfico, necesitarías
tener como un ojo de águila...
pero bueno, vamos a resolverlo
por el método de suma y resta
y para esto lo que quiero preguntarte es,
¿a esta ecuación que tengo
aquí arriba, a la primera ecuación, existirá
algo que le podamos sumar o en su dado caso,
restar a esta ecuación, de tal manera que
se elimine una de estas dos variables?
Y la respuesta es que sí,
si nosotros agarramos la segunda ecuación
y la restamos de la primera ecuación,
se va a cancelar la "x" porque
"3x" menos "x", esto nos va a hacer,
que todo lo que tenga que ver con "x" se cancele.
Entonces, del lado izquierdo voy a restar "3x" más "y", mientras que del lado derecho,
voy a restar 1.79 y puedo hacer eso tan fácil,
la respuesta es que sí,
porque estas dos cosas son iguales,
recuerda que tenemos aquí una igualdad,
yo sé que "3x" más "y" es igual a 1.79
y por lo tanto lo que estoy haciendo
de un lado de la ecuación,
lo voy a hacer también del otro lado de la ecuación,
así que déjame poner aquí un menos y voy restar...
espera, espera...
mejor lo voy a poner aquí...
menos que multiplica a su vez a "3x" más "y",
esto es lo que voy a restar del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación y bueno,
esto es lo mismo que "-3x" menos "y",
entonces "-3x" menos "y",
esto es lo que voy a restar del lado izquierdo,
mientras que del lado derecho
voy a restar 1.79
y ojo, recuerda que puedo hacer esto porque
yo sé que estas dos expresiones son iguales,
esto es lo que me dice la segunda ecuación
y por lo tanto ya puedo restarlos,
¿y cuánto es esto?
déjame poner esto por aquí...
Bueno, de hecho otra forma de verlo,
es que estás multiplicando
la ecuación de abajo por -1,
la estás multiplicando entera por -1,
para que tú puedas aplicar el método
de suma y resta, y ahora si,
¿qué me queda?
De este lado tengo "3x" menos "3x",
pues estas dos cosas se van,
"3x" menos "3x" es "0x",
pero pues 0 por "x" no es nada,
por lo tanto se cancelan.
Y después me queda "4y" menos "y",
"4y" menos "y" es lo mismo que "3y".
Bueno, esto es lo que pasa del lado izquierdo,
mientras que del lado derecho,
¿qué va a pasar?
Tengo 2.84 menos 1.79,
¿cuánto es esto?
Pues como el de arriba es más grande me queda
1. y 79 para 84 es 5, entonces 1.05,
"3y"es igual a 1.05, ahora qué pasa si yo divido ambos lados de esta ecuación entre 3,
voy a obtener el valor de "y".
Y "y" es igual a 1.05 entre 3,
1 entre 3 aquí no me cabe ninguna vez,
bajo el 1 y después tengo,
10, aquí me va a quedar un 1 y aquí un 0,
10 entre 3 cabe 3 veces, 3 por 3 es 9,
10 menos 9 esto es lo mismo que 1,
bajo ahora el 5 y me queda 15 entre 3,
15 entre 3 es 5, entonces 5 por 3 es 15 y bueno,
ya aquí no me queda nada, ¿no?
15 menos 15 esto es 0... 0...
¡Y ya sé cuánto vale "y"!
"y" vale 0.35,
es decir, cada una de las gomitas vale 0.35 centavos.
Perfecto, ya tengo el valor de "y"
y una vez que ya obtuve el valor de "y",
recuerda, no hemos acabado el problema.
Ahora lo que necesitamos saber
es el valor de "x",
¿y cómo obtengo el valor de "x"?
Bueno, me puedo fijar
en cualquiera de estas dos ecuaciones
y de aquí despejar a "x", entonces me voy
a fijar en la ecuación de abajo que decía.
"3x" más "y" es igual a 1.79
y después voy a sustituir el valor de "y",
"y" vale 0.35, entonces me va a quedar
"3x" más 0.35, esto es igual a 1.79
y si resto 0.35 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿qué me queda?
Bueno, del lado izquierdo
solamente me va a quedar "3x",
porque 0.35 menos 0.35,
se van, se cancelan
y del lado derecho me queda 1.79 menos 0.35,
esto es lo mismo que 1.44,
5 para 9 es 4, 3 para 7 es 4
y bajamos el 1, 1.44 y bueno,
ahora lo voy a dividir entre 3 para sacar el valor de "x", así que vamos a hacerlo.
1.44 entre 3 y me queda 0 veces, aquí 0,
bajo un 1, pongo un punto y bajo el 4,
14 cabe 4 veces en 3, 4 por 3 es 12,
después de aquí hago la resta,
no me cabe, pero lo voy a hacer acá,
14 menos 12 es 2 y después
bajo el 4 y aquí me queda 8, 8 por 3 es 24,
perfecto, ya con este tengo el valor de "x",
"x" es igual a 0.48,
"x" vale 0.48 pesos
y ya con esto puedo poner las respuestas.
El precio de cada uno de los
chocolates es de 48 centavos
y el precio de cada una de las gomitas
es de 35 centavos, 0.35 pesos.